from day one they've been a couple
who've made an impact an exciting new
prospect for the monarchy able to
connect in a new way for their
extraordinary decision to break the mold
and step away has left the royal family
in turmoil Harry and Megan didn't
consult with any of their relatives
before releasing that statements meaning
even their closest family members had no
idea how this was going to work despite
the fact that the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex on their own website very clearly
set out a plan of how they see it all
playing out put together not by the
palace but we suspect a PR firm in
America the website is Harry and Megan
explaining how they think their new
roles are going to work splitting time
between North America and the UK staying
in their newly renovated Frogmore
cottage with their security still paid
for by the taxpayer but this evening the
urgency to sort this out became clear
with News the Queen the Prince of Wales
and the Duke of Cambridge have all now
directed their teams to work together at
Pace with governments and the Sussex
household to find workable solutions
that are expected to take days and not
weeks in Africa last year Harry's
frustrations were clear when I tried to
ask him a question and got a response
I'd never had before
that's short conversation what do you
hate to achieve through it
[Music]
that was important for you to come here
and talk to them the intense media
interest and the princes desire to
protect his family may be part of the
reason for this dramatic decision but a
close friend of the prince told us his
friends were gobsmacked wondered who was
advising him and said he had become
increasingly distant something that has
been noticed by those who followed him
closely over the years he was a joy to
work with and then he married Megan and
he became suddenly mr. dua and mr.
miserable in many ways they've got you
know a very wise father and a very wise
grandmother and I should have they
should have sat down with them and said
look this is what we want to do and it
would have been worked out much much
better than this this is like a seismic
shock that arose a source who has worked
closely with Prince Harry told me this
seemed to be an innovative move by the
couple but did question the way it was
announced and the potential damaged
their reputation
especially following suggestions they
went public after the Queen advised them
not to the scrutiny they faced has made
them a close team United in their desire
to make this new step now some of those
big decisions about their future will be
made by the institution they have at
times found so stifling Rhiannon Mills
Sky News at Buckingham Palace